Imagine tiny robots made of living heart cells
swimming towards you being guided by laser
light.
Well, now that’s a thing.
We live in the future people!
Hello everyone!
I'm Crystal here for DNews.
In what seems like a plot from a science fiction
film, scientists have now created tiny swimming
robots shaped like jellyfish and stingrays.
They claim to be using these mechanical copy
cats to study propulsion, test biological
materials, and find new vehicle designs, but
I can’t be the only one imagining swimming
armies of tiny robots, am I?
Didn’t think so.
When mechanical objects like this mimic biological
systems it’s called “biomimicry”.
Some scientists believe that since biomimicry
builds on millions of years of evolution it’s
a more effective and efficient approach to
engineering.
In my favorite recent example of this, a team
of scientists lead by Kevin Parker at Harvard
created a 1/10th-scale version of a ray fish
with a tiny gold skeleton and a rubber body
that is powered by approximately 200,000 rat
heart muscle cells.
This biological hybrid machine can swim through
an obstacle course in a salt solution with
a little help from lasers.
It’s so creepy!
The reason they used heart cells is because
of the way they beat, contracting together
in response to stimuli.
They started by placing the heart cells on
the top of the robot.
But these weren’t ordinary heart cells.
They were modified to contain a light detecting
protein usually found in our eyes, making
them activate in response to light.
This meant the researchers could signal the
cells to contract simply by flashing a light
at them.
When activated, the cells contract down, bending
the skeleton, and when they release, the flexible
wings rebound to neutral -- just like a live
ray or...the beating of a heart.
So now they could make the robot swim.
But, since the contraction of the cells happened
on both sides of the mechanical ray at the
same time, the robot was impossible to steer.
So, they further modified the cells to make
the ones on the right and left wings responsive
to different wavelengths of light.
Flashing both wavelengths at the same time
caused the ray to swim forward, but flashing
one or the other activated only one “wing”
of the ray and could turn the vehicle.
After accomplishing this, the team did what
anyone would do really, and started building
obstacle courses for their robot like they
were designing a biomimetic video game.
Robot bio-hybrids are relatively new, and
others have mimicked aquatic animals like
sea turtles, jellyfish, and now stingray.
Obviously this is all REALLY COOL, but why
do we want to build robots out of biological
materials in the first place?
Well Stanford Professor of Engineering John
O. Dabiri says it all comes down to energy.
With traditional robotic systems, Dabiri says,
quote “the robots would run out of energy
before they took over the world.”
But biological systems are REALLY EFFICIENT
at using energy.
If you want to make smaller, more powerful,
faster robots, improving energy use is a good
way to do that.
Biomimetic jellyfish or stingrays don’t
require batteries, gas, or solar panels.
They use the same source of energy as the
rest of the cells in our bodies do: Glucose,
a form of sugar, which scientists put in the
water to feed the cells.
So...at this point, the robot only swims if
it’s in a glucose and salt solution, at
body temperature, with particular lightwaves
flashing at it.
But, it’s still an exciting step forward
toward making biomechanical robots that sense,
respond, and move on their own.
In other words: Intelligent robots made from
live biological materials could be coming
soon.
What could possibly go wrong?
To learn more about the ways human engineering
can benefit from biomimicry, check out this
video
by Trace!
If you could make any robot that mimicked
any animal, what animal would you choose?
Let us know down in the comments and don’t
forget to like and subscribe to get more DNews
every day.